Speaker 1: All right.
Let's talk a little bit about the shifting
dynamics of the 2024 Republican primary.
A number of interesting things happening over
the last 48 hours.
First and foremost, failed former President
Donald Trump's very I would call it an increasingly
unhealthy obsession with Florida Republican
Governor Ron DeSantis seems to be getting
worse and worse and worse.
Trump completely out of control, obsessed
with Ron DeSantis posting endlessly to truth
social about him, sometimes multiple times
per hour.
Now, I pulled a bunch of truths from a 24
hour period.
Since then, Trump has continued posting.
So like, I could give you ten more of these,
but I'm not going to do that to you.
But just to give you a sense of how obsessed
Trump is with a guy who, as of right now isn't
even running against him and who, by all reasonable
assessments, can't even beat Trump.
I mean, Trump's already over 50% in most Republican
primary polls.
DeSantis is in the low twenties with a campaign
that seems to be slowing down big donors abandoning
DeSantis before he even announces, okay, so
it's not even really clear.
DeSantis is a major threat to Trump regardless.
Look at this Trump going after DeSantis for
COVID death numbers, by the way.
Pretty unfair, because you really should go
by rates.
Trump just posting a chart of COVID deaths.
But it's like Florida has a huge population,
so it would make more sense to look at COVID
death rates regardless, he says.
So explain why did Ron DeSantis do a good
job?
Highly overrated.
New York had fewer COVID cases.
Now New York is better than Florida.
For a while, Florida was better than New York.
No new tricks, just the per capita confusion
that we've always been seeing.
Trump continuing to sanctimonious had nothing
to do with Israel or the moving of the U.S.
Embassy to Jerusalem.
Never so much as mentioned it to me, it was
the last thing on his mind.
Desanctis wasn't even governor yet.
It was December of 2017 and I barely knew
him.
He has turned out to be a total flameout.
This is the kind of disinformation I thought
only the Democrats would put out.
No wonder Desanctis is dropping like a rock
in the polls.
Terrible.
Trump continuing.
And remember, this guy's not running yet,
and he's also doing terribly in the polls.
But Trump is just obsessed.
Collapsing at home, DeSantis travels to Israel
and proclaims he moved U.S. Embassy to Jerusalem,
not Trump.
But it doesn't stop there.
Again, guys, this is like all within a few
hours.
This sanctimonious had a failed campaign.
When he was running for governor, he was ready
to drop out, was way behind.
Then I capital E endorsed him.
It wasn't a lowercase E endorsement, it was
a capital E endorsement.
And he went big league but artificially up.
The real Desanctis, however, is the guy we
are all watching crash a burn a really bad
politician.
Enjoy the trip Ron Trump.
Then retro thing, a guy named John Rich saying,
quote, I don't understand the logic of DeSantis
running.
Let's just say he beat Trump in the primary,
which won't happen.
But let's hypothesize.
If he won, there wouldn't be one true Trump
supporter left that would vote for him and
he would be destroyed in a general election.
This is a losing proposition no matter how
you look at it.
So why on earth would he voluntarily run head
on into the woodchipper?
Now, this one is interesting for two different
reasons.
Trump and failed Arizona gubernatorial candidate
Kerry Lake have both been pushing this idea.
If DeSantis somehow won the primary, no Republicans
would vote for him in the general.
This is starting to be an odor of maybe boycott
the general if Trump doesn't win the nomination,
which I absolutely love.
The best scenario for Democrats would be for
Trump to lose the primary and then for Republicans
to either stay home in protest or to write
Trump in, or even better, for Trump to run
third party and take ten 15% of that vote.
Those would be absolutely dream scenario.
So that's an interesting thing that Trump
is now starting to signal boost.
The idea of Republicans wouldn't vote for
DeSantis in the general.
They wouldn't carry Lake is starting to signal
boost that idea that's number one.
Number two that's interesting about this is
the idea of really seeming to try to push
to Santos not to even run.
It seemed at one point that Trump was maybe
looking forward to the idea of a contested
and heated primary.
But now that Trump's talking about I might
not even debate now that Trump's talking about
maybe DeSantis shouldn't even run, it seems
that the tide has turned a little bit, and
the idea here is to prevent DeSantis even
from announcing, okay, Trump.
Continuing on truth, weirdly going after Kayleigh
MCENANY, his own former press secretary, saying,
quote, I guess Kayleigh is no longer speaking
so favorably about sanctimonious.
Now, that is capital P polls are shot.
And he said that after Kayleigh posted strong
foreign policy interview from Trump on Tucker
Carlson.
Trump excels when he talks policy.
He all right.
Emphasizes his experience and reminds Americans
how safe our country was on his watch.
This is just showing you how sort of petty
Trump is.
Even though this post from his former press
secretary is praising Trump.
I guess at some point she praised the Santos
and Trump really didn't like that.
So he's still going after her.
Then Trump continuing and I could keep going
all day, but this will be the last one Trump
posting.
I couldn't care less if Ron DeSantis runs.
But the problem is the Capital B bill he is
about to sign, which allows him to run without
resigning from being governor totally weakens
capital E election capital.
I integrity in Florida.
Instead of getting tough and doing what the
people want.
Same day voting voter ID, proof of citizenship,
paper ballots hand count.
This bill guts everything.
So this is endless.
This all these messages I just showed you
are all from a few hour period.
Trump is obsessed with the Santos.
It seems to be becoming an unhealthy obsession.
But the strategic question here, of course,
is if DeSantis doesn't announce, is it only
going to get worse for him in the sense that
Trump is starting actual campaign stuff, he's
doing events and he even is going to do a
town hall with CNN.
Let's talk
about
that next.